ladies and gentlemen and welcome to this
virtual meeting meeting of council
all members of the council have been
invited to attend this meeting
electronically and we've received
apologies from councillors bunting
duffield minis new and shaw because of
their work commitments and also
counsellor mrs churchill
and do we have any further apologies
please uh
council councillor rigby i put it in the
chat
thank you councillor rigby i've also had
apologies from councillor kerry
any more counselors um new
walsh taylor bennett dr carr
and stennett mr mayor
um councillor jerome uh who uh will
hopefully be able to join us soon
thank you you got all those in
thank you
thank you i'm sure we all appreciate
that uh the timing makes it difficult
for some members
um moving on um can i remind everybody
when participating in this virtual
meeting to please remember to mute your
microphone when not speaking
to use the chat facility to indicate to
me if you would like to speak
and finally to leave the meeting once it
ends with a little red button
um so moving on item one announcements
it is my very sad duty to um inform
council
of the passing of former councillor
david merrill
uh mr merrill was the member for village
ward from 1983 to 1987
and for bowdoin ward from 1988 to 2008
he had a very distinguished career on
trafford council
rising in the end to become deputy
leader and was the mayor of trafford
from 1997
to 1998. so can we all just
take a moment of silence just to
remember mr merrill and his family
please thank you
thank you very much everyone um
obviously the funeral has taken place in
accordance with the current restrictions
but i have been in contact with his
family
to convey uh trafford's fondest wishes
to them
moving on um the item one leader do you
have any further announcements please
no thank you mr man thank you
item two then um i invite councillor tom
ross the executive member for finance
and investment
to introduce the report and move the
recommendations regarding the
redesignation of leisure center
refurbishment earmarked reserve
councillor ross please thank you mr
mayor um this afternoon i'm seeking
council's approval to redesignate the
leisure center refurbishment earmark
reserve
as the leisure reserve council will be
aware that restrictions to control the
spread of covert 19 were introduced in
march and required
the closure of all leisure centers the
actions to protect public health from
the virus were
crucial however the impact has caused a
considerable deterioration of trafford
ledger's trading position
last week the government announced that
indoor leisure facilities and swimming
pools will be allowed to open from the
25th of july
however the necessary requirement of
social distancing measures and an
enhanced cleaning regime
will mean that trafford leisure's
financial position will not improve
immediately
trafford leisure does not have reserves
in place and would not be able to secure
a finance from a commercial lender
trafford leisure was set up with the
council as sole shareholder and
responsible for underwriting its
financial position
therefore if traffic ledger ceased to
trade as a company the council would be
required to pick up the responsibilities
for the staffing
and other associated costs
in the light of this there is a strong
case for the council and trafford
leisure to work together to keep the
company's financial position
under review on a month by month basis
you'll be aware council agreed to
provide a loan to trafford leisure on
the braces that it was short-term
support urgently required to deal with
the immediate effects of the pandemic
restrictions
trafford leisure then approached the
council to request request a grant to
cover their projected trading deficit to
the end of the trading year
however the financial position of the
council has meant that it is not
open to us to provide a further facility
by grant or loan
what we can consider and recommend is
the redesignation of the reserve
originally earmarked to cover the risks
to income during the future leisure
centre redevelopment work
the value of this reserve is 968 000
pounds
we have sought the advice of leading
council to provide assurance as to the
lawfulness of any decision to provide
further support
to offset trafford leisure's ongoing
liabilities
that assurance has been provided in the
meantime we have employed max associates
to work with trafford leisure
to review the financial projections to
the end of the financial year
we will also be carrying out a full
review of our leisure strategy later in
the year
if the council agrees to the
recommendation in the paper payments
will only be
advanced on a month by month basis and
be subject to the approval of the
corporate director
for finance and systems i stress again
that if we do not agree to this course
of action
then the council would be request
required to pick up the responsibilities
for the staffing and other associated
costs where trafford leisure to cease
trading
thank you mr mayor i move the report
thank you councillor ross um i
understand this will be seconded by
councillor weston
councillor patel mr sorry councillor
patel
thank you mr mayor um i'd like to second
this report
um council ross has covered the
financial and legal background
uh to this report could i just please
make a few broader points about our
leisure service
the kovic crisis has had and will
continue to have a big impact on council
services
and more widely on our economy sectors
like leisure have been particularly hard
hit
and will continue to be impacted by
social distancing requirements
and more broadly by potential reshaping
of the leisure market
work continues with traffic ledger to
develop a reopening plan that maximizes
income
and reduces expenditure and we will be
working closely with trafford leisure on
a month-by-month basis to review the
support needed
this reopening plan will be communicated
publicly in the next week or so
i would like to thank trafford leisure
and council staff who have been working
with dedication and
under great pressure to protect protect
our leisure offer
it's been a very challenging and
uncertain time
offices and our partners have
demonstrated that even under such
circumstances a constructive way forward
can be found
the decision to allow more flexibility
with the allocation of this reserve is
welcome
and will help stabilize leisure services
in trafford in the short to medium term
what's needed in the longer term however
is a more sustainable leisure offer
this decision today provides us with a
breathing space which will allow us
in conjunction with our partners to
undertake an in-depth review
of what and how we deliver our leisure
services locally
just like to finish really the impact on
of the kovi crisis has really
highlighted health inequalities in
trafford
and we will continue to work closely
with partners to narrow this gap
thank you mr moon
thank you councillor patel um i haven't
had any indications that anybody wishes
to speak on this
um can anybody who does wish to do so
please
indicate on the um chapter
no there are a couple of hands mr and
the participant
got to look at hands um
whose other hands i'm sorry i can't keep
track of everyone's hands
all right councillor coggins please
thank you chair uh green group will are
happy to support this move today
um it's really important we know that
there is a strong
covert related public health argument
for keeping people as active as we can
at the moment there are very few things
we can do
to to help um to help residents of
trafford
through the next year and one of them is
to help keep people um strong and fit
and active so i think supporting our
leisure centers
and and everything else that we can do
that will support people being fit and
active
and being in the strongest condition
they can it's very important at the
moment
and my one uh word of caution is just
having read through the paper and having
read through the previous paper which i
believe went through in 2015 that was
also
actually an urgent uh piece of business
just to um
to echo cancer patel's calls for a more
sustainable leisure strategy in the long
run we
we we need to show that we really value
our leisure centers and that we have a
long-term sustainable plan so
i look forward to seeing that coming
through in in the medium term
thank you thank you very much councillor
cobbins
councillor myers please
yes thank you mr mayor um i think it's
fair to say that in view of the
um the current situation the coveted
situation
there's no real alternative to this i
think it's a
well formulated approach and i can't see
any
realistic alternative but what i would
say is in
section 17 of the report it talks about
um
the future um beyond 2021
i just wonder what plans have been made
if the financial situation
isn't any any better at that time so in
other words
we're still in a difficult situation
with with finance
bearing in mind that the council is also
in a difficult situation with finance
where will the money come to support it
because at the end of the day it's a
non-statutory function thank you mr
mayor
thank you councillor myers councillor
ross you don't have to come back to that
book do you wish to
thank you mr matt and first of all thank
you to councillor coggins for her
comments and also to
to to councillor myers in terms of um
what councilor maya says about the
replenishment of the reserves obviously
at the moment we're continuing to
press the government to recognize the
situation with leisure centers which i
know is an issue
across the country the government has
come forward with some proposals
but it's not quite clear yet that we
would be covered from them so we're in
as far as i understand it we're still in
discussions with uh with the government
about that
and we'd hope that we'd get additional
support through to um
support our leisure strategy our leisure
centres
and obviously importantly to build up
those reserves again
thank you very much councillor ross um
i've had no
further indications um so with that
um could i um take a view as to whether
this can be agreed by consensus
or is there any dissension in that
everyone happy councillor evans
consensus
mr mayor thank you councillors coggins
and new gross everyone happy yes happy
for consensus
thank you everyone uh with that um i
think we can uh
take it as it is all agreed um
and therefore the recommendations have
been approved
thank you everybody for agreeing to this
meeting at the last minute i'm sure you
agree it's um
an important subject to discuss um
before we go can i once again just thank
all members who have
contributed to helping our most
vulnerable residents over the lockdown
period
i'm sure it has been very much
appreciated i know a lot of people have
been involved
so thank you very much stay safe and
that is the end of the meeting ladies
and gentlemen